leurs convictions n'hésitant pas à
tordre les faits et à utiliser tous les
moyens pour imposer leur vérité
[Musique]
la communication emmanuel macron aux
prêts à des jeunes via twitter instagram
tik tok est ce que depuis sa prise de
fonction c'est devenu son circuit
préférentiel là où avant en tout cas on
avait l'impression que emmanuel macron
avait un contenu politique à nous vendre
une ligne politique des réformes il se
vend comme étant cool et où ça n'a plus
rien fait pour se rapprocher des jeunes
mais parce qu'ils sont beaucoup trop
déconnecté de la sphère politique il
pense que ça va ramener les jeunes à la
politique dont le désintéresserait en
lieu et place de politiser les jeunes ça
dépolitise la politique en la rendant
encore plus que nesc justement c'est une
nouvelle forme de communication assez
verticale utiliser des influenceurs pour
moissac hommes politiques personnelles
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est
vraiment nouveau d'utiliser des
célébrités pour faire de la propagande
politique on s'en fiche nous on veut
quelqu'un qui dirige la france comme
c'est son travail en notre nom pour nous
est dans notre intérêt à tous
[Musique]
les réactions se multiplient au
lendemain de l'attaqué drone qui a visé
la résidence du premier ministre irakien
l'onu condamne fermement une tentative
d'assassinât est les etats-unis
dénoncent eux un acte apparent de
terroristes ou staff al qadi me sortir
des appels au calme et à la retenue
les compagnies aériennes se prépare à un
afflux de voyageurs après 20 mois de
restriction les états unis rouvrent
leurs frontières sol en dix chevaux
personnes vaccinées kingson qu'ovide
obligation vaccinale que joe biden
souhaitait voir instaurée en entreprise
cour d'appel fédérale américaine suspend
la mesure pour les employés des
entreprises
200 personnes
[Musique]
les premiers résultats officiels
devraient être connus dans la matinée
nicaragua voter aujourd'hui pour élira
son président sans surprise l'actuel
chef de l'état daniel ortega devrait
être réélu pour un quatrième mandat en
raison de sa politique populaire selon
certains observateurs parce que
l'opposition eut gelé pour d'autres
[Musique]
et
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez crt france
joe biden condamne ce soir fermement
l'attaqué terroriste contre le premier
ministre irakien même réaction du côté
de l'onu mustapha l'académie n'a pas été
blessé il est sorti indemne de cette
attaque aux drones piégée selon ses
services elle a visé sa résidence cela
s'est passé dans la nuit de samedi à
dimanche dans la zone verte de bagdad un
périmètre ultra protégée qui abrite
également l'ambassade des états unis
ainsi que des bâtiments gouvernementaux
pas de revendication pour le moment une
nouvelle escalade dans la crise que
traverse l'irak à l'heure où les partis
mènent des tractations pour en vue de
former des coalitions parlementaire
yamina wendel da
le premier ministre irakien attaqué dans
sa résidence mustapha al-qasimi a été
victime d'une tentative d'assassinât au
drone piégée il en ressort un den
ma résidence a été la cible d'une
agression lâche dieu soit loué je vais
bien ainsi que ceux qui travaillent avec
moi les forces de sécurité héroïque et
l'armée de votre pays travaillent pour
protéger l'irak et sa stabilité les
lâches missiles et drones ne
construisent pas les nations et le futur
nous travaillons à la construction de
notre patrie en respectant l'état et ses
institutions et en construisant un
avenir meilleur pour tous les irakiens
cette attaque dans laquelle deux gardes
du corps ont été blessés n'a pas été
revendiquée
selon une source sécuritaire
une roquette s'est abattue sur la maison
du chef du gouvernement irakien dans la
zone verte de bagdad un périmètre ultra
protégée au coeur de la capitale
certains habitants craignent le chaos
alc arbres elle montre à quoi va viser
la maison de mustapha al-qasimi dans la
zone verte conduira au chaos cela va
créer un vide sécuritaire vide
économique et invite dans les services
un vide dans tout et cela affecte le
processus politique
et la mairie l'attak intervient au
lendemain d'une importante manifestation
menée par des partisans du groupe pro il
rendu acheter le chaabi il accuse le
gouvernement d'avoir truqué les
résultats préliminaires des dernières
législatives
dans cette élection l'alliance de
conquête vitrine politique du ht chaâbi
a perdu un grand nombre de ses sièges
aujourd'hui le premier ministre appelle
au calme de son côté washington a
également réagi nous sommes soulagés
d'apprendre que le premier ministre est
indemne cet acte apparent de terrorisme
que nous condamnons fortement visé le
coeur de l'état irakien nous sommes en
contact étroit avec les forces de
sécurité irakiennes chargées de faire
respecter la souveraineté et
l'indépendance de l'irak et avons offert
notre assistance dans leur enquête sur
cette attaque
l'attaqué de la résidence du premier
ministre irakien fait craindre une
escalade de la violence alors que les
résultats définitifs des législatives
devraient être publiés d'ici quelques
semaines
cette tentative d'assassinât s'inscrit
donc dans un contexte politique tendu
l'analyse de riadh sidaoui expert du
monde arabe directeur du karabakh
nous avons bien que dans les démocraties
si grande partie quand même qui
n'accepte pas les résultats on a un
grand problème d'ordre éthique dans un
structure elle est ce que ces élections
sont ont été justes transparentes est ce
qu'il ya eu une fraude électorale comme
elle ait des chabbiha à réclame de toi
de toute façon la démocratie c'est son
fondé sur le consensus et qu'il n'y a
pas un processus malheureusement pas
parler d'une démocratie c'est pour cette
raison que je répète journée toa système
parlementaire dans le monde arabe qui
sont dans l'impasse totale le système et
raquettes le système parlementaire
irakien le système parlementaire
tunisien le système parlementaire
libanais les trois sont des répliques
que donc on voit bien que sonné un grand
problème avec le système parlementaire
dans le monde arabe d'ailleurs même je
pense d'autres pays occidentaux et
seront issues problème et depuis la
chute de saddam hussein et
l'intervention américaine l'instabilité
politique perdure en irak regardez
le 20 mars 2003 la coalition américano
britannique lance une intervention
militaire en irak après avoir accusé le
pouvoir de saddam hussein de détenir des
armes de destruction massive
face à la faible résistance des forces
irakiennes la coalition prend le
contrôle de bagdad le 9 avril 2003 la
statue de saddam hussein est renversé
par un blanc des américains il restera
comme le symbole de sa chute
début octobre 2003 coup de théâtre en
rapport américain du groupe d'inspection
de l'onu reconnaît qu'aucune arme de
destruction massive n'a été retrouvée en
irak le 13 décembre 2003 saddam hussein
est capturé par les forces américaines
près de tikrit au nord de bagdad il sera
jugé et pendu trois ans plus tard en
2005 des élections sont organisées pour
élire les membres de l'assemblée
nationale constituante ainsi que les
conseils provinciaux le scrutin boycotté
par les sunnites est reportée par les
chiites majoritaires en irak dans la
foulée la nouvelle constitution institue
le fédéralisme et légalise l'autonomie
du kurdistan le 22 février 2006 le
dynamitage dans mausolée chiite au nord
de bagdad déclenché une spirale de
violences entre sunnites et chiites
les affrontements feront des dizaines de
milliers de morts jusqu'en 2008
en janvier 2014 les djihadistes du
groupe etat islamique prennent le
contrôle de deux villes dans la province
d'al-anbar falloudja et ramadi le groupe
s'empare de mossoul avant de contrôler
près du tiers de l'irak
fin 2014 les forces irakienne lance la
contre offensive avec l'aide d'une
coalition internationale emmenée par
washington
la victoire face aux djihadistes et
finalement proclamé fin 2017 en octobre
2019 des manifestations massives se
produisent dans les grandes villes
irakiennes
les protestataires dénoncent la
corruption le chômage et la
déliquescence des services publics la
révolte est durement réprimée elle fait
près de 600 morts et trente mille
blessés en avril 2020 mustapha al-qasimi
est chargé de former un gouvernement
il a l'oreille des états unis et de
l'iran les élections législatives
anticipées du 10 octobre dernier
renforce la majorité parlementaire du
leader chiite moktada al sadd r le
principal opposant dalle kazimi et
marque en fort recul des factions pro
iranienne dans la tente des résultats
définitifs ses anciens paramilitaires
dénonce une fraude électorale
op art aux états unis pays le plus
touché par le cos vite en nombre de cas
que de mort avec plus de 750 mille décès
pour augmenter la couverture vaccinale
de maiden souhaite instaurer une sorte
d'obligation vaccinale en entreprise
d'ici au 4 janvier sous peine d'être
testé très régulièrement mais une cour
d'appel fédérale au texas vient de
suspendre la mesure le temps d'examiner
de potentiel sérieux problèmes
constitutionnels fin de citation un
revers de taille pour le président
américain qui continue toutefois à
défendre son projet projet que nous
détaille à laurence hézard riche
professeur d'histoire contemporaine à
l'université d'arras
le banni de plus de 100 salariés
devraient donner du temps libre et
rémunérée aux employés pour eux se faire
vacciner et récupéré des effets
secondaires maintenir une liste des
employés vacciner prévenir les employés
testé positif obliger les non vaccinés à
porter un masque tout cela à leurs frais
mais les compagnies ont le choix entre
obliger leurs employés à se faire
vacciner ou
comment dire offrir à leurs employés les
choix que j'ai indiquées et donc
évidemment ça serait plus coûteux
pourrait n'être à 58% de la population
qui a une double vaccination c'est
effectivement très bien parti et en ce
moment
ça plafonne les dons coni fait je
suppose que cette ce décret vise à
accélérer la la vaccination sans
recourir ou risque politique purement
politique parce que juridiquement baden
pourrait le faire d'un décret qui
obligerait à vacciner les états unis
pour ouvrir leurs frontières aériennes
aux personnes vaccinées dès demain après
20 mois de restriction les avions des
compagnies aériennes de 33 pays vont à
nouveau pouvoir se poser sur le sol
américain une bonne nouvelle pour nombre
d'entre elles qui dépendent fortement de
leur liaison vers les états unis les
voyageurs eux aussi se réjouissent c'est
le cas de ce couple de britanniques ils
n'ont pas vu leur fisc depuis un an et
demi
chaque jour nous avons vérifié les
nouvelles dans les journaux et écouter
la radio pour savoir quand les états
unis allaient s'ouvrir à nous tout à
coup un vendredi soir on a annoncé que
les etats-unis allaient ouvrir leurs
frontières aux britanniques
nous avons manqué son 30e anniversaire
que nous avions l'intention de fêter en
grand on a raté ça
puis il a obtenu son premier emploi
permanent aux états unis ce qui était
énorme nous voulions être là avec lui et
nous ne pouvions pas l'être c'était
triste c'était frustrant nous avons eu
notre trentième anniversaire de mariage
que nous aurions normalement célébrer
avec liam en france alors que les
chiffres du cabinet repartent à la
hausse ces manuels macron s'adressera de
nouveau aux français mardi soir le chef
de l'état devrait évoquer la crise
sanitaire mais aussi la relance
économique et les réformes à cinq mois
de la présidentielle cette reprise à
épidémie qu'elle concerne l'ensemble du
vieux continent l'europe redevenu selon
le m s l'épicentre de l'épidémie alors
dans certains pays européens les
restrictions ont fait leur retour yves
olivier b
des policiers qui contrôlent des
attestations une situation devenue
courante dans la plupart des pays
européens
face au regain de l'épidémie de covin en
grèce le gouvernement a renforcé ses
mesures ce samedi notamment en imposant
aux non vaccinés des tests pour accéder
à tous les espaces publics à l'exception
des magasins de produits de première
nécessité à partir d'aujourd'hui les
règles sur les certificats prouvant soit
les vaccinations le fait d'avoir eu la
maladie ou les tests de diagnostic
négatif entre en vigueur et sont aussi
requis pour les zones extérieures c'est
la nouveauté en cas de non respect de la
loi amendes peuvent atteindre un montant
particulièrement élevé au moins 5000
euros pour les contrevenants loin d'être
aussi sévères l'islande a elle aussi
rétabli des mesures de ré fiction depuis
vendredi malgré une population
entièrement vacciner à plus de 89 % chez
les plus de 12 ans mais face aux 179
nouvelles infections recensés en 24
heures les autorités de l'île ont
réinstaurer la distanciation d'un mètre
dans les espaces publics avec port du
masque lorsque celle ci ne peut être
respecté une décision accueillie
différemment par les habitants
c'est difficile de travailler avec un
masque dur de respirer quand on essaie
de travailler rapidement
oui fatigué mais ça me dérange pas pour
autant je me suis habitué
autre source potentielle de
contamination les lieux festifs comme
les discothèques sous les barres ils ont
désormais l'obligation de fermer deux
heures plus tôt et les rassemblements
publics ne doivent pas dépasser 500
individus contre 2000 auparavant pas sûr
cependant que ces restrictions pousse
les réfractaires à se faire vacciner une
situation qui commence d'ailleurs a
irrité un certain nombre de soignants
c'est une pandémie une épidémie de non
vaccinés s'il n'y avait que les gens
vaccinés qui sont en échappement à cause
de limite et c'est sans le savait on
pourrait gérer on est dans les problèmes
à cause des non vaccinés pour des
raisons religieuses pour des raisons de
complotisme ou de suivre d'aidés
décidées complètement folle donc pas les
restrictions arrivé de bien falloir que
les gens se fassent vacciner on n'a pas
tellement choix
ce jeudi l' oms a affirmé être très
préoccupé par le rythme de transmission
du virus en europe devenue l'épicentre
de la pandémie de co vide
ah les nicaraguayens étaient appelés aux
urnes aujourd'hui élections générales
législatives et présidentielle
l'opposition avait appelé ses partisans
à rester à la maison à l'actuel chef de
l'état à daniel ortega brigue un
quatrième mandat il devrait l'emporter
sans surprise les premiers résultats
officiels sont attendus dont la matinée
redrado c'est
des élections sur le point d'acter un
quatrième mandat pour daniel ortega au
pouvoir depuis 2007 ses principaux
adversaires sont emprisonnés ou en exil
simples citoyens ou acteurs de la vie
politique
nombreux sont les nicaraguayens à être
allé chercher l'asile au costa rica
gueule
je suis pleinement convaincu que tous
les exilés sont unis par cet objectif
commun nous voulons qu'ortega partent
nous voulons que la démocratie revienne
au nicaragua nous voulons des élections
libres pas ce qui se prépare dimanche
nous voulons la liberté pour les
prisonniers politiques
pour faire simple ortega enlève la
parole au reste des partis maintenant
son candidat parce qu'il est terrifié
par la campagne
ortega est terrifiée à l'idée de revoir
l'opposition dans les rues
concernant la couverture médiatique de
ses addictions elle est parfois rendues
difficiles certains journalistes
étrangers sont empêchés d'entrer dans le
pays mais le passé révolutionnaire du
leader sandiniste ses réalisations
sociales ou encore son discours anti
ingérence étrangère continue de séduire
une partie de la population
ils ne veulent pas d'un président comme
le nôtre qui se bat pour le bien de ce
peuple pour notre souveraineté qui est
la chose la plus importante à défendre
pour un peuple et ils veulent toujours
être impliquées dans cette affaire parce
qu'il ne pense pas qu'il soit juste que
le peuple se réveille que le peuple se
bat pour son bien-être
nous sommes pour daniel ortega et son
épouse rosario ce sont les personnes qui
ont été à l'avant-garde de la vérité sur
la situation au nicaragua sur la
pauvreté au nicaragua malgré les
nombreux problèmes que nous avons eus
les nombreuses fausses accusations qui
ont été portées nous sommes ici à l'aise
et heureux et personne ne manque de ces
repas quotidiens
ce dimanche plus de 30 mille policiers
et militaires sont déployés par le
pouvoir pour surveiller ces élections
sous tension
invention et illusions réaction ceux des
manches du front polisario au lendemain
des déclarations du roi du maroc dans un
discours retransmis hier à la télévision
nationale mohamed 6 a affirmé que le
sahara occidental n'était pas à négocier
le territoire est discutée par rabat et
les indépendantistes sahraouis le roi
marocain plaide pour un règlement
pacifique du conflit du conflit mais
réitère son refus de toute indépendance
de l'ancienne colonie espagnole le front
polisario net en garde
le peuple sahraoui n'arrêtera pas sa
lutte tant que le maroc ne mettra pas
fin à son agression et à son occupation
illégale du territoire de la république
sahraouie le roi du maroc est bien
consciente que la république sahraouie
voisine du royaume du maroc est une
réalité irréversible dont il ne peut se
détourner le maroc siégeant à ses côtés
lors des événements multilatéraux au
niveau continental et international
un premier jour d'une nouvelle campagne
de désobéissance civile contre l'armée
au soudan des militants pro civils sont
descendus dans la rue près de deux
semaines après le coup d'état les forces
de sécurité ont tiré des grenades
lacrymogènes sur plusieurs cortèges des
dizaines de manifestants ont été arrêtés
les protestataires réclament le
rétablissement du gouvernement déposé et
la fin du partage des autorités de
transition avec l'armée pour laisser les
seuls civils organiser les premières
élections libres du pays depuis 30 ans
la rue est entré en résistance une
montée des tensions alors que les
négociateurs de la ligue arabe sont
arrivés à khartoum pour tenter de
renouer le dialogue entre militaires et
civils décryptage à de la situation tout
à l'heure à 21h
le sommet des chefs d'état de la cédéao
la communauté économique des états de
l'afrique de l'ouest s'est achevée chien
accra au ghana à l'ordre du jour de la
réunion la situation en guinée et au
mali dirigé par des juntes militaires
suite à un coup d'état principales
décisions du sommet un durcissement des
sanctions contre plusieurs dirigeants
après que dans une lettre officielle le
gouvernement malien a annoncé qu'il ne
peut pas tenir les élections
présidentielle et législatives en
février 2022 comme initialement prévu le
mali et la guinée suspendue de la cedeao
je vous propose d'écouter deux
présidents du ghana
le mali et la guinée de nation soeur
dont l'adhésion à notre communauté est
actuellement suspendue en raison de la
récente prise de pouvoir par les
militaires de leur gouvernement en
violation du protocole de la cedeao sur
la démocratie et la bonne gouvernance
qui prévoit un scrutin libre et
transparent comme seuls moyens légitimes
pour l'accession au pouvoir dans la
communauté
thomas pesquet et ses coéquipiers
devraient relever revenir sur terre
aujourd'hui leur retour est finalement
repoussée à demain en raison de
mauvaises conditions météorologiques
l'astronaute aura passé six mois dans
l'espace il a remis les clés de la
station spatiale internationale à son
nouveau commandant le cosmonaute russe
anton chkaplerov la correspondance à
moscou devient goffman
les clés de la station spatiale
internationale sont désormais entre les
mains du cosmonaute russe anton
chkaplerov la cérémonie officielle une
formalité symbolique a eu lieu ce samedi
à bord de la station spatiale
internationale
l'astronaute de l'agencé spatiale
européenne thomas pesquet qui était de
commandes de l'iss depuis le 4 octobre
2020 s'apprête lui à revenir sur terre
avec l'équipage de la mission de crue
dragon's den comme le veut la tradition
la cérémonie de passation de pouvoir
s'est conclue au son d'une cloche donne
à lire les deux spationautes russes et
français ont exprimé beaucoup d estime
l'un pour l'autre je vous propose
d'écouter
je ne peux exprimer à quel point je suis
reconnaissant de tout le travail réalisé
par tant de personnes à travers le monde
pour permettre à un si petit groupe pour
devenir dans l'espace pour le bénéfice
de tous
je suis très fier d'être le commandant
de cette expédition
nous allons réaliser de nombreuses
expériences spatiales et je sais que
nous allons vivre une expédition très
intéressante à bord
interesting
expedition diamond board anton
chkaplerov est arrivé sur les ss le 5
octobre dernier accompagné de l'équipe
de tournage du film décide du lait piris
il est clean shipping co qui ont
travaillé pendant douze jours en orbite
sur le premier long métrage tourné dans
l'espace à bord en tant qu'appelé rohff
âgé de 49 ans il s'agit de la quatrième
mission sur l'iss dupuis 2011 est pilote
de formation il a suivi le cursus
d'ingénieur explorateurs puis deux
cosmonautes c'est aujourd'hui lundi
cosmonautes russes les plus expérimentés
avec à son actif cinq cent trente deux
jours en orbite et 14h28 dans l'espace
ouvert je capte les roms va maintenant
diriger la station spatiale
internationale jusqu'à son retour sur
terre prévu pour le printemps 2022
et retour sur la mobilisation mondiale
pour le climat paris londres mexico ou
encore glasgow haute de la coop 26
partout dans le monde les militants se
sont rassemblés samedi pour alerter sur
l'urgence climatique
tour d'horizon en images avec cathy
bauza
après les paroles les actes voilà ce
qu'ont réclamé les manifestants ils
étaient plusieurs dizaines de milliers
hier à se mobiliser un peu partout dans
le monde pour alerter sur l'urgence
climatique londres sydney ou encore
paris quelques centaines de personnes
étaient rassemblées devant l'hôtel de
ville militants et associations ont
donné de la voix pour protester contre
les dirigeants mondiaux accusée
d'inaction climatique aujourd'hui il ya
énormément de le discours et la coop
c'est vraiment le marché aux fausses
solutions en particulier à travers les
droits des changes du carbone mais aussi
tout ce qui se passe au niveau de
l'union européenne à travers vous avez
peut-être vu ça les jeux pour faire
rentrer le nucléaire et le gaz dans les
énergies dites propres et donc de vent
pouvant bénéficier de financements
publics on lutte contre ça c'est un
glasgow que la mobilisation a été l'une
des plus importantes les manifestants
ont défilé dans les rues à proximité du
centre de congrès où se tient la coque
26 après une semaine de discussions et
de négociations
les annonces des dirigeants s'enchaînent
23 nouveaux états dont le canada et la
pologne se sont engagés à sortir du
charbon d'ici 2030 sans oublier les
alliances conclues par une centaine de
pays pour enrayer la déforestation et
réduire les émissions de méthane de 30%
à nous avons globalement progressé et je
pense que les gens ont été constructifs
dans les salles de négociations archi
junghee assiégée et pourra vous en
donner une meilleure idée mais je pense
comme je lé deal hier lors de la
conférence de presse que nous arrivons
au moment où les choses se corsent où
nous allons devoir prendre des décisions
difficiles en termes de texte nous
allons passer aux négociations entre
ministres et je ne sous-estime
certainement pas la difficulté de la
tâche qui nous attend
les négociations vont se poursuivre à
partir de demain avec un objectif
parvenir un texte commun le 11 novembre
prochain
deux marins disparus et des centaines de
migrants secourues en moins d'une
semaine les tentatives de traversée de
la manche ont considérablement augmenté
ces derniers jours au large du nord et
du pas de calais une pression migratoire
qui pose de nombreux problèmes à calais
et dans les villes alentour juliette
lamy
anaïs et ludovic militants associatifs
sont toujours déterminés à poursuivre
leur grève de la faim pour dénoncer le
traitement des migrants à calais alors
cotée depuis le 11 octobre l'aumônier du
secours catholique âgé de 72 ans a lui
mis un terme à son action ce jeu je
demeure totalement solidaire de la
détermination qui est la leur car les
propositions faites jusqu'à ce jour par
les autorités ne tiennent pas compte des
itinéraires des personnes exilées à qui
on accorde jamais la parole je reprends
le chantier préalable à la mise en
service sur calais d'un nouvel abri
hivernale à destination des personnes
exilées les plus vulnérables cela ne
veut pas dire que je passe sur un autre
registre moins radicale carte pour moi
dès la fin novembre j'irai couché dans
une des jungles à laquelle je demanderai
l'hospitalité une décision qui
intervient au lendemain des déclarations
faites par didier leschi patron de
l'office français de l'immigration et de
l'intégration il a été envoyé sur place
comme médiateur par le gouvernement
mercredi il a annoncé la création d'un
sas d'hébergement de nuit de 300 places
les migrants seront ensuite orientés
vers des hébergements pérenne en dehors
de calais même si ces propositions ne
satisfont pas les associations locales
elle pourrait soulager la commune
voisine de grande synthe située près de
dunkerque la situation migratoire il est
tout aussi urgente plus de 1500 migrants
sont entassés dans des conditions
difficiles contre 400 il ya quelques
mois le maire de la ville a envoyé ce
vendredi un courrier à gérald darmanin
pour tenter de faire bouger les choses
j'entends - du ministre qui prennent ce
dossier en pleine responsabilité à
calais un médiateur a été nommé par le
gouvernement pour aller à la rencontre
des associations et des protagonistes et
des donneurs d'ordres à grande synthe le
médiateur de l'état c'est le maire de
grande synthe cette situation est
complètement insupportable inacceptable
je demande qu'un médiateur soit nommé
ici également à grande synthe et je
demande aussi une table ronde que le
ministre dans ma nage bien et si la
grande crainte pour qu'on puisse
ensemble évalué la cible est aussi
apporter des réponses précises et
concrètes ces derniers jours les drames
se multiplient sur le littoral mercredi
près de 800 personnes ont été secourues
dans la manche après le naufrage de leur
canot le lendemain un migrant a été
retrouvé sans vie dans une embarcation
échoué sur une plage de wissant le même
jour dans la soirée un autre migrant a
trouvé la mort après avoir été percuté
par un ter près de calais depuis deux
ans les traversée illégale de là hanches
explose cette semaine un nouveau record
a été franchi
853 migrants ont rejoint les côtes
britanniques en l'espace d'une journée
pourtant à 21000 le nombre de personnes
ayant traversé clandestinement depuis le
début de l'année et c'est la présente
édition prochain journal dans une
trentaine de minutes à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
le volontarisme politique atteint ses
limites dans les français sont de plus
en plus sceptique
[Musique]
y'a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi qui ai des candides il
n'y a pas d'alternative en sort du
politique il est clair que tout le monde
attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez déçu l'univers
uniforme c'est quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir